this episode was made possible by Wix
build your own professional website with
Wix by following the link below all
right this week we're gonna do something
a little bit different I'm here in
California for VidCon I'm staying at
this house with about 15 other
educational youtubers so I figured why
not pick their brain see what insights
they can offer us and hope you guys
learn something useful so five years ago
I I was working as a valet attendant at
a at a steak house back then and people
would tell me oh you have a great voice
for radio ly you have a you have a voice
you should get on radio you should try
to get in a radio and that wasn't the
direction that I was planning on taking
my life I had never planned on getting
into radio and the advice didn't stick
with me until years later when I started
making YouTube videos and I think the
thing that I would have told myself most
back then would have been to have to
find what you're good at or more this it
would be to find the intersection of on
one side of something you're good at and
on the other side of what you enjoy
doing and at that time I knew neither of
those things
I knew neither what I was good at and I
didn't know what I liked doing so I
would have tried my advice to myself
five years ago would been to have tried
to find those two things out earlier
than I did
because if I had found them out earlier
than I did then I would have been doing
what I'm doing now years earlier than
when I actually started the most
important thing is that I never give up
writing because every time you write
even if it sucks you get better and when
it's even and when it sucks you almost
get better cuz you like realize why it
sucks and then you fix it and I would
every day I didn't write was a day I
think that I could have been a little
bit better at writing now I would say
that's my advice
[Music]
like practice a lot more tools and like
start more bad YouTube channels like
tears here's my fourth YouTube channel
and I had all the experience of like
editing because I've tried and failed
like it a challenge I started didn't go
anywhere but I was still able to learn
from editing those bad videos that never
got seen by anyone so yeah start more
projects even if they don't meet
anywhere just for the experience of
doing it so the most valuable piece of
advice I ever really got was when I was
living in Malaysia and I'd lost a lot of
friends back home like I went over there
cuz I couldn't get a job back home I was
having a bit of a personal identity
crisis on how I defined myself and I
didn't really like my job and I didn't
know what to do with that and over those
three years that I was there I got I
learned not to deploy myself by things
external to myself whether that was like
people family
possessions and by not defining myself
by those things I learned to be far more
self-sufficient as and I became much
more successful as able to start the
YouTube channel because I didn't need
money anymore and that's when things got
really interesting
I think the good advice is to just keep
that passion for YouTube alive like
you're going to have setbacks you're
going to have challenges if it's okay to
feel bad about them right I mean its
setbacks and challenges it's fine to
feel bad but it's also important to like
forgive yourself and not get too caught
up on them and just make sure you keep
your your passion and focus and keep
that keep pursuing that and keep
focusing so my advice would be don't be
afraid to spend time figuring yourself
out
so in YouTube you're gonna want to
figure out a distinct hook that will get
viewers onto your channel but it doesn't
come immediately for every channel so
it's you know you look at other channels
that it seems that way but there's most
likely there's a story behind it where
they had some years where they were
really refining their craft so don't be
afraid to have that but also don't be
discouraged by early failures those are
lessons for you keep keep making videos
keep being consistent and eventually
you'll put together that video that'll
pop and things will change
[Music]
well as you can see I have these two
dope cars here and this mansion that is
totally mine so all my advice is very
warranted so my best friend and I did a
podcast about this recently so this has
been on the brain the advice I would
give to myself ten years ago would be to
practice empathy when talking with other
people so I think a lot of guys have
this problem and I had this problem
especially bad we automatically think of
solutions to the problems that our
friends and our loved ones have when
they're having them but the problem is
that they're feeling pain when something
bad happens so if you're coming at them
with a solution immediately they are not
ready to receive that solution and what
their need of actually is emotional
support like a shoulder to cry on and I
had to learn this the hard way I
actually had a girlfriend break up with
me because I had an inability to feel
empathy and to be that shoulder I would
constantly just tell basically what I
thought she should do instead and it
made me kind of come off as a jerk so
over the past two ten years I've
consciously worked to become a more
empathetic person to become a more
patient person just be the person who
can listen without suggesting something
and that ends up working out a lot
better than constantly having to be the
person who has the answer to every
problem
[Music]
my advice to younger people is to go
outside more there's all sorts of sorts
of studies and stuff that you can read
saying how it helps mental development
and stuff and mentally government this
stuff is good so go outside more go
hiking go kayaking do anything upside as
much as possible before you have a job
think of it as your job or something I
don't know just go outside more that's
my thesis goodbye
[Music]
if there's anything that all these
youtubers have in common it's that
they're busy we don't have time to work
with a fiddly website design platform I
can personally recommend Wix because
it's super easy to build exactly what
you need with Wix you can build amazing
professional websites for just about any
application whether you want to host
videos share your photo gallery book
clients sell products or just about
anything else you could ever want if you
need a professional website for your own
personal use or for e-commerce music
hotels or restaurants Wix does all the
heavy lifting like hosting custom
domains email marketing and more
allowing you to focus on the creative
side of things you have total creative
freedom over your websites allowing for
limitless possibilities and you don't
even have to be a web designer Wix
caters to everyone regardless of skill
level whether you're a novice business
owner or a seasoned website builder so
if you want to build your very own
professional website visit Wix by
following the link below
[Music]